massive aha driving down the road
with my brother ben and uh
realized that something really unique
happens in conversation when you're on a
road trip
and that is you're fed all of this data
all around you so we just drove by a
marriott
and i talked about the article that i
saw that
people were scraping marriott was being
scraped off a building so we was
wondering did marriott go out of
business
which i don't know if it's true maybe
we'll fact check that and put a yes or
no here
um but then we drove by ikea and
started talking about the sustainability
of ikea and my thought
is what would happen if we were to
channel all of the
data the conversational data that
literally flies by
at 60 miles an hour on a road trip
what if we were to channel that into our
conversations even when we were
stationary
whether it was an elevator or a board
meeting or
a classroom or anything else and in this
video
i'm gonna unpack and share a few ways
that i think
that you can make that happen here we go
[Music]
if you've been following on the channel
for any amount of time i hope that was
fun to kind of break out of the
studio format this video is totally
inspired by that car trip with my
brother
ben and so we're going to unpack how to
bring up topics
in conversation i'm going to label this
entire video
the road trip method and
i don't know if anybody's come up for
before i didn't google it before making
this video
but we're going to call it the road trip
method and we're going to call it the
road trip method because
of the natural default i think when
people are on
a road trip or driving in a car to talk
about what they
see all of the data that is surrounding
them now
i'm going to break that down a little
bit me and my co-founder partner in
crime will wise wrote a book called ask
powerful questions
create conversations that matter which
is
a little bit to my surprise continue to
just like sit on a
best sellers list on amazon so i'm gonna
unpack three tools that we share in this
book
that we're gonna say encapsulates the
road trip method
so by the end of this video what's in my
brain about how to create conversations
that matter and how to bring
up new topics in conversation and keep a
conversation filled with life
and energy and curiosity as opposed to
this like
trailing ending conversation with like
so right and the attempts of avoiding
that
and avoiding that and maybe even more
importantly
creating conversations that are really
valuable to you
and to the people that you're talking
with number one
is listen to the music behind the words
right so often when people say things
right we take them at face value but
we're not a cop or a lawyer or anybody
else we don't need to just hear the
facts
right we can we can hear the depth
behind what somebody's saying and so
some specific ways that you can hear
music behind the words because just
generally you could take that idea
and skip to the next section in the
video right just the the mindset of
listening to the music behind the words
just recognizing that
if somebody shows you this what they're
actually saying is all
is all filled in the space in between as
well and so it's the unstated feelings
that are happening
it's the opinion that they're not quite
sharing but is
sort of embedded it's the process of how
the conversation is going right so i
work with a lot of
leaders that are very like me to some
extent
adhd busy and so walk into their office
or hop on with them on zoom and they're
clearly doing 17 other things
right so music behind the words they
might be saying something but there i
can see
all of this other stuff going on there
so listening to music behind the words
increases the amount of data that you
get in a conversation
by at least 20 sort of an arbitrary
number but thinking about road trips
having
you know constant novel data coming at
you at 70 miles per hour
listening to the music behind the words
increases the level of data that's in
the conversation you've just got to tune
into it
right we oftentimes we find what we're
looking for
and we hear what we're listening for so
if you're just listening for the facts
you're just going to hear the facts if
you're just listening for that person to
be annoying that's all you're going to
hear but if you listen for their
strengths
their fears their aspirations the
background the whole story
you're going to have a very very
different conversation part number two
of the road trip method
is you have to believe that conversation
is exponential and what i mean by that
is um if you
ask so one of the four questions that
often gets asked in conversation when
you first meet a person like
where are you from what do you do how
are you
well just maybe just three um and so if
you ask where are you
and that person says uh where are you oh
my goodness where are you from
is a better way of phrasing that so if
you ask a person
where are you from and they say
massachusetts
right that's it that is true i am from
massachusetts um
but i don't live in massachusetts but uh
i am from there i live in pittsburgh
pennsylvania now and my social security
number and address is
just kidding um if they just share
massachusetts right even though they
only gave you
one word of data you might be able to
tell were they excited to show that they
were from massachusetts
were they completely indifferent did
they share it in a way of like
like i'm from massachusetts um right was
there is there hesitation so there's
that
um data there's also just everything
that you know about massachusetts
and your experiences with massachusetts
and when i say conversation is
exponential even though they share just
one word
the way they feel about massachusetts
you're what you're curious about
massachusetts
and the prior experiences that you've
had in massachusetts
are three of many probably but just
three potential pathways that you can
continue on
so if you continue on this pathway right
there may be
three others that come out and then
three others and then three others and
then three under
and this is what i mean when i say
conversation is exponential
the problem is when we're in the moment
and we're wondering how to bring up
new topics in conversation or how to
continue a really meaningful discussion
um if we get stuck at all we get stuck
and we think oh there's nothing left to
talk about so if i'm on a date
with my wife kate and conversation
is going going going and then that topic
sort of just kind of fizzles
or dies we're going to continue that
dialogue in
very two very different ways if i
believe that conversation is exponential
versus if i think oh there's nothing
left to talk about
right we've been married for seven years
we've talked about everything under the
sun that we can possibly
talk about anything else that lit that
is an extremely limiting belief
that will prevent um topic exploration
in conversation whereas if i say even
though we've been talking for 30 minutes
and so i believe if someone spoke for 30
minutes you have at least
300 different pathways of potential
conversation
if you're listening to the music behind
the words and then the third idea here
comes directly from ask powerful
questions and it is this idea of asking
reflective questions so you can you know
just pull questions out of thin air out
of your own curiosity
reflective questions is a little bit
different it's where you
reflect what you've heard somebody else
say
and then ask a question rooted in it and
you kind of get you feed two birds with
one worm when you do that
because when you reflect what somebody
else has said
it's like a mirror that illuminates
something
to them right oftentimes when we speak
even as i'm recording this video right
now and speaking like
i i can't hear myself talking and really
process that
and think about what i'm going to say
next so when you reflect what somebody
else says
it illuminates what they're saying to
them
and oftentimes it's amazing like even if
you reflect verbatim exactly what
somebody else has said
you reflect that back to them it's
amazing how frequently someone will jump
and be like no
no that's not what i mean and then
correct and extend that conversation
and get to the heart of the matter it's
a phenomenal tool to create
conversations that matter to you
and to the other person now a reflective
question
is you reflect a piece of what some
somebody said
and then add on a question let's do this
kind of odd in a video format right now
so we're having an interaction right
you're watching a video which i've
recorded
in the past and you're seeing it live
now so if i were to reflect right in
this moment
i might say hey it seems like you're
watching this video
you're getting toward the end you must
be enjoying it to some degree
i'm wondering what has really stuck out
to you about this video
right did you see it that was a
reflective question i reflected what was
happening
in this moment and then i added on a
question rooted in my own curiosity at
the end
and jumping back to number two with that
word curiosity
conversation is exponential if
if you are genuinely naturally curious
about that person that idea etc the cool
thing is
that natural genuine curiosity
is actually a choice it's not a gene
right curiosity
you weren't just born with or without
curiosity in fact i would argue that
we're all born with an immense amount of
curiosity and if you've ever met a three
to five year old
you know that that's true and so we lose
touch with that curiosity a little bit
as time goes on but we still can choose
to flip it on
and so to channel the road trip method
and make a road trip
level quality conversation happen in a
classroom
a board room a living room anywhere else
listen to the music behind the words
believe that conversation is exponential
and
ask really great reflective questions
rooted in your own curiosity
i'm chad littlefield it was awesome
hanging out in cyberspace with you
if you want a free digital version of
ask powerful question there's a link
below to download a ton of free
resources
along with a bunch of conversation topic
questions that i created in a deck
called we connect cards
and a whole ton of other resources that
will help you create conversations that
matter
and just in case you were wondering oh
my brother drives it is
a nice shiny green lambo
kia soul have an awesome day